à notre zoo le soir du
Le 28 février, la première fusée est tombée, la voici
se trouve au musée car ce document est le sien
doit être sauvé dans la nuit du 11 au 12
mars, trois autres roquettes sont tombées, que nous
montrer comme les banques
ça peut se vérifier
[musique]
Je dois dire que le zoo est maintenant
fonctionne bien les gens sortent
le travail est nettoyé et nourri d'animaux et
les animaux personne n'a fait de mal aux gens
Même
avec en plus on peut aussi ma femme
vétérinaire et nous avons la possibilité même en
la nuit
influencer positivement si
soudainement une situation ira si
il y aura une situation dont vous aurez besoin
décidera d'urgence